let's now continue with our super fast
journey through history and one thing I
want to point out because I already
touched on it in the previous video is
while we talk about this ancient history
I'm also referring to some stories from
the Old Testament so let's call that
religion now the reason why I'm doing it
is because the religion is such a big
part of our of our modern culture it's
clearly especially the Old Testament is
the basis of three major world religions
today and so it can help us hopefully
create a little bit more of a narrative
in our head on some of these ancient
events because a lot of these events
described in the Old Testament have a
historical context there was a Babylon
there was a neo-babylonian empire well
hear and talk about Nebuchadnezzar in
this video there was there were pharaohs
these things are described in the Old
Testament
now there's other things in the Old
Testament that have less of a historical
context where we really don't have
evidence yet of did they happen or did
they happen in the way that is described
in the Old Testament we might be able to
find that evidence over time and then
there's clearly a lot of events that are
not described in the Old Testament but
we are able to find evidence we're able
to find documents writing hieroglyphs
we're able to find artifacts and date
those artifacts we're able to find ruins
and the fun of history is to try to
figure out well what do we know and what
do we not know and can we construct
narratives that make sense and over time
whether we're talking about events that
are referred to in the Old Testament or
things where there's a large historical
basis for it as we understand more these
dots might change a little bit or at
least our understanding of how they
occurred or the causality so that's
that's one of the really fun things
industry and I encourage you everything
that you hear me say don't take it for
granted look it up yourself and come to
your own conclusions so with that said
let's continue and I'll review a little
bit from the previous video we're in
1700 BC is the time of Hammurabi you
have the Code of Hammurabi famous famous
as a written code written code of laws
now we believe if you the stories of
Abraham because there are parallels
between the Old Testament and the Code
of Hammurabi it is often placed Abraham
as a as a biblical figure is often
placed in or shortly after the time of
Hammurabi and so it's Abraham of or and
this migration to Canon which would
eventually become the kingdom of Judea
and Israel modern day where the states
of Israel and Palestine are that
migration people place it at around 1200
or sre around 1700 BCE
once again roughly in the time of
Hammurabi now we don't know this there
is not a lot of historical evidence here
but it fits kind of the historical
context especially with the especially
with the code with the Code of Hammurabi
now we fast forward a few hundred years
and now we're firmly on the side of
religion where these are stories from
the Old Testament we haven't found a lot
of historical evidence yet of the
migration from of the Jewish people to
Egypt the famous story of Joseph so
that's the migration which is placed
tends to be placed around 1500 BCE 1500
BCE and once again I'm going to put a
question mark here and so when we look
at the our timeline this is Abraham
going from Mesopotamia and then to what
is now or to establish this tribe and
what eventually becomes Judea Israel
they're there for several hundred years
you have the story of Joseph Abraham's
grandson he becomes a vizier of the
Pharaoh his family eventually joins him
but then the Jewish people get enslaved
according to the Old Testament for
several hundred years until they are
freed in the books of book of Exodus by
Moses and they are led back to Judea and
so this part right over here we are
definitely let me Circle down a color
you can see this part right over here
we're definitely operating outside of a
lot of historical evidence but we
believe but that that the the Exodus
from Egypt back to Judea this is often
placed around 1200 BCE so I know my map
is getting a little bit a little bit
1200 BCE and once again I'm going to put
a question mark there because we don't
really know but that's where we believe
that the set was essentially the tribe
of Jewish people it's now established as
a real state as a real Kingdom the
United Kingdom of Israel and Judea and
you have the famous Kings King Saul King
David King Solomon King Solomon famously
noted for the construction of the first
of the first temple at Jerusalem and now
we're going to fast-forward because in a
few hundred years that temple gets
destroyed by the neo-babylonian empire
so let's fast forward a little bit the
neo-babylonian empire led by
nebuchadnezzar ii often known as the
Chaldean Empire this is approximately
and I'm going very high level in this
video 600 BCE before the Common Era
secular way of saying before the time of
Christ before Christ you might often see
BC which would refer to before Christ
BCE is referring to before the Common
Era but 600 BCE and 600 BC are referring
to the same date but you have the
neo-babylonian empire and I'll stress
the word neo because even though you
hear a lot about Babylon when we talk
about ancient Mesopotamia you notice
that Babylon was only dominant for
relatively short periods of time when we
look at the this you know multi thousand
year view of things actually most of the
time in in this period the Assyrians
were dominant with their capital at
Nineveh but when we get to roughly 600
BCE you have never condesa the second he
is the king the Emperor of this
neo-babylonian empire and he goes on he
searches for conquest he wants to expand
his empire and he's really set on taking
over the pharaohs among other people or
the Egyptians but on his way he's
unsuccessful on taking over the Pharaoh
so let me so this is him on the way to
try to take over try to take over the
Pharaohs he is unsuccessful to try to
take over Egypt but
on the way he's able to march through a
lot of what we now call the Middle East
and relevant to the Old Testament he
destroys the first temple that Solomon
built so he destroys that temple and
then he takes the Jewish people captive
at or according to the Old Testament and
that is the famous Babylonian captivity
and that was Nebuchadnezzar who does it
now Nebuchadnezzar's Empire his dynasty
is relatively short-lived in the whole
scheme of things the neo-babylonian
empire the Chaldean Empire because by
the time we get to the the or we get a
little bit further into the sixth
century BCE so we're around
539 539 BCE this is when you have the
Persians come and invade the
neo-babylonian empire the Persians led
by Cyrus the Great so now you have the
Persians come and take over the
neo-babylonian empire and on our
timeline here this is the Persians going
on going and taking over more and more
territory they take over
Mesopotamia they're able to take over
what we you know Judea and and actually
this whole region that that is kind of
the modern Middle East and they are
successful this is a big deal because
look how long this this line of Egyptian
civilization is they are able to take
over Egypt and they keep going their
conquest and as we'll see in the next
video they get very frustrated because
they're not able to take over the Greeks
even though in a lot of ways the Greeks
did not seem as significant of an empire
as the Egyptians or the Babylonians but
we will continue that in the next video